IN FACT, IT’S ONE OF THE FEW
BRIGHT SPOTS IN AN OTHERWISE
DARK MOMENT.
WELL, IF YOU PUT ALL THE OTHER
CONCERNS ASIDE, THE CORONAVIRUS
EPIDEMIC IS A PROFOUND SHARED
EXPERIENCE FOR THE COUNTRY.
EVERYBODY IS BEING AFFECTED IN A
BIG WAY.
SOME PEOPLE ARE ON THE BRINK OF
INSANITY FROM BEING COOPED UP IN
SMALL APARTMENT.
OTHERS ARE SHARING MEALS FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A LONG TIME.
ADAM COROLLA IS A COMEDIAN, A
PODCAST HOST, ONE OF THE MOST
POPULAR IN THE WORLD.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK, I AM YOUR EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL.
WE TEXTED HIM LATE LAST NIGHT,
ASKED HIM TO COME ON AND PUT
SOME PERSPECTIVE ON THE
SHUTDOWN.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM HERE
NOW.
HEY, ADAM.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU ARE IN
SECLUSION WHERE YOU ARE, BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE AND IT’S A
BEWILDERING EXPERIENCE.
HOW SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT THIS
QUESTION MARKS TO GO WELL, FIRST
THING, I’M DOING MY PODCAST
EVERY DAY.
SEE YOU CAN HEAR IT.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THE GEARS
TURNING.
IT’S A PRISON SENTENCE.
IT’S A SHORT PRISON SENTENCE.
AS THEY SAY, AS THE CONVICTS
SAY, YOU CAN DO THE TIME OR THE
TIME CAN DO YOU.
I FIGURE YOU SHOULD DO THE TIME,
MEANING GO OUT, BUILD A
TREE HOUSE WITH YOUR SON AND
DAUGHTER.
COOK LASAGNA WITH YOUR WIFE.
DON’T LET THE TIME TO YOU.
YOU DON’T END UP WITH A FACE
TATTOO AND A TOILET FILLED WITH
PRISON WINE.
YOU GO OUT AND USE THIS LITTLE
SNAPSHOT IN LIFE TO LIVE YOUR
LIFE.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE ARE FINDING
THAT HARD AND I’M NOT
CRITICIZING OR JUDGING, BUT IT’S
JUST, IT’S SO DIFFERENT.
I MEAN, PEOPLE SEEM LIKE THEY
ARE STRUGGLING WITH BEING
CONFINED AND BEING SOLITARY.
>> YEAH, WELL, I HAVE A
PHILOSOPHY, WHICH IS I WILL JUST
SAY THIS TO ALL YOUR VIEWERS.
IN YOUR LIFE, WHEN HAS CHANGED
REALLY BEEN BAD BIG PICTURE?
YOUTHE GIRL FROM FRIEND THAT DUM
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AFTER A
COUPLE YEARS, IMMEDIATELY, IT’S
BAD.
ANOTHER MONTH, IT MIGHT STILL BE
BUT TWO YEARS, I THINK YOU LOOK
AT THESE LITTLE CHANGES IN LIFE
IS A GOOD THING.
THAT’S THE TIME YOU LEARN TO --
WHATEVER IT IS, I THINK
PHILOSOPHICALLY, CHANGE IS
ALWAYS GOOD, EVEN NEGATIVE
CHANGE IS WITH TIME.
>> Tucker: SO COME OUT ONE OF
THE CHANGES YOU ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO?
>> WELL, I THINK JUST GETTING
OFF OF THE TREADMILL OF LIFE.
I THINK WE ARE ALL SORT OF
FUNNELED TOWARD THIS TREADMILL.
I KNOW YOU FEEL IT.
I FEEL IT.
WE ALL FEEL IT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE HAY WHILE THE
SUN SHINES.
LITERALLY JUST SOME QUIET TIME.
IT’S LIKE FORCED MEDITATION FOR
THOSE OF US WITHOUT A YOGI.
I TALKED TO KEVIN BACON ON MY
PODCAST THE OTHER DAY.
HE SAID HE AND HIS WIFE DID A
CROSSWORD, OH, NO, THEY DID A
5,000 PIECE PUZZLE.
HE SAID, FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER, THEY HAD BEEN MARRIED FOR
33 YEARS.
MY WIFE SAID, LET’S DO A PUZZLE
TOGETHER."
WITH THAT EVER HAPPEN QUESTION
WAS THE ONE THAT’S AMAZING.
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE ARE GOING
TO LEARN NOW THAT WE ARE FORCED
TO TAKE A PAUSE, GET OFF THE
TREADMILL, EXPERIENCE A LITTLE
SILENCE?
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT OURSELVES.
HOPEFULLY, WE ARE GOING TO LEARN
THAT IT’S NOT ALL ABOUT THE
BOTTOM LINE.
HOPEFULLY WE ARE GOING TO LEARN
THAT FAMILY IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN YOUR SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
THEY ARE BOTH IMPORTANT, BUT I
THINK WE HAVE A CHANCE TO STOP
AND REPRIORITIZE AND SHIFT JUST
A LITTLE BIT.
>> Tucker: HUH, DO THINK
PEOPLE WILL DO THAT?
THAT WOULD REQUIRE GETTING OFF
NETFLIX TOO, RIGHT?
>> AGAIN, DO YOU WANT TO DO THE
TIME OR DO YOU WANT THE TIME TO
DO YOU?
YOU WANT TO COME OUT WITH A
GREAT NOVEL OR DO YOU WANT TO
COME OUT WITH A VENEREAL DISEASE
DISEASE?
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
THE GREAT NOVEL OR THE VENEREAL
DISEASE.
I THINK WHAT YOU SAID IS ABOUT
THE MOST HELPFUL THING I HAVE
HEARD AND I MEAN THAT.